i remember the very first time i went to
a nice
restaurant a really nice restaurant it
was for a law firm recruitment dinner
and i remember beforehand the waitress
walked around and asked whether we
wanted some wine so i said sure
i'll take some white wine and she
immediately said would you like
sauvignon blanc
or chardonnay and i remember thinking
come on lady stop with the fancy french
words and just give me some white wine
but i used my powers of deduction and
recognized that chardonnay and sauvignon
blanc were two separate types of white
wine
and so i told her that i would take the
chardonnay because frankly that was the
easiest one to pronounce for me
so i had a lot of experiences like that
during my first couple of years as a law
student at yale
because despite all outward appearances
i'm a cultural outsider
i didn't come from the elites i didn't
come from
the northeast or from san francisco i
came from a southern ohio steel town and
it's a town that's really struggling in
a lot of ways a ways that are indicative
of the broader struggles of america's
working class
heroin has moved in killing a lot of
people people i know
family violence domestic violence and
divorce have torn apart families
and there's a very unique sense of
pessimism that's moved in
think about rising mortality rates in
these communities and recognize that
for a lot of these folks the problems
that they're seeing are actually
causing rising death rates in their own
communities so there's a very real sense
of struggle now i had a very front row
seat to that struggle my family
has been part of that struggle for a
very long time
i come from a family that doesn't have a
whole lot of money
the addiction that plagued my community
also plagued my family and even sadly
my own mom there were a lot of problems
that i saw
in my own family problems caused
sometimes by lack of money
problems caused sometimes by lack of
access to resources and social capital
that really affected my life
if you had looked at my life when i was
14 years old and said
well what's going to happen to this kid
you would have concluded
that i would have struggled with what
academics call
upward mobility so upward mobility is
an abstract term but it strikes it's
something that's very
core at the heart of the american dream
it's the sense
and it measures whether kids like me who
grow up in poor communities are going to
live a better life
whether they're going to have a chance
to live a materially
better existence or whether they're
going to stay in the circumstances where
they came from
and one of the things we've learned
unfortunately is that open mobility
isn't as high as we'd like it to be in
this country and interestingly
it's very geographically distributed
so take utah for instance in utah
a poor kid is actually doing okay very
likely to live
their share and their part in the
american dream but if you
think of where i'm from in the south in
appalachia
in southern ohio it's very unlikely that
kids like that will rise the american
dream
in those parts of the country is in a
very real sense just a dream
so why is that happening so one reason
is obviously economic
or structural so you think of these
areas they're beset by these terrible
economic trends
built around industries like coal and
steel that make it harder for folks to
get ahead
certainly one problem there's also the
problem of brain drain where they're
really talented people because they
can't find high skill work at home
end up moving elsewhere so they don't
build a business or non-profit where
they're from
they end up going elsewhere and taking
their talents with them
there are failing schools in a lot of
these communities failing to give kids
the educational leg
up that really makes it possible for
kids to have opportunities later in life
these things are all important i don't
mean to discount these structural
barriers but when i look back at my life
and in my community something else was
going on something else
mattered it's difficult to quantify
but it was no less real so for starters
there was a very real sense of
hopelessness in the community that i
grew up in
there was a sense that kids had that
their choices didn't matter
no matter what happened no matter how
hard they worked no matter how hard they
tried to get ahead
nothing good would happen so
that's a tough feeling to grow up around
that's a tough
mindset to penetrate and it leads
some times to very conspiratorial places
so let's just take one political issue
that's pretty hot
affirmative action so depending on your
politics you might think that
affirmative action is either a wise
or an unwise way to promote diversity in
the workplace or the classroom
but if you grew up in an area like this
you see affirmative action as a tool
to hold people like you back that's
especially true if you're a member of
the white working class
you see it as something that isn't just
about good or bad policy you see it as
something
that's actively conspiring where people
with political and financial power
are working against you and there are a
lot of ways that you see
that con conspiracy against you
perceived real but it's there and it
warps expectations
so if you think about what do you do
when you grow up in that world you can
respond in a couple ways one you can say
i'm not going to work hard because no
matter how hard i work it's not going to
matter
another thing you might do is say well
i'm not going to go after the
traditional markers of success like a
university education or a prestigious
job
because the people who care about those
things are unlike me they're never going
to let me in
when i got admitted to yale a family
member asked me if i had pretended to be
a liberal to get it
by the admissions committee seriously
and it's obviously not the case that
there was a liberal box to check on the
application
but it speaks at a very real insecurity
in these places
that you have to pretend to be somebody
you're not to get past
these various social barriers it's a
very significant problem
even if you don't give into that
hopelessness even if you think let's say
that your choices matter and you want to
make the good choices
you want to do better for yourself and
for your family it's sometimes
hard to even know what those choices are
when you grow up in a community like i
did
i didn't know for example that you had
to go to law school to be a lawyer
i didn't know that elite universities as
research consistently tells us
are cheaper for low-income kids because
these universities have
bigger endowments can offer more
generous financial aid i remember i
learned this when i got the financial
aid letter from yale for myself
tens of thousands dollars in need-based
aid which is a term i'd never heard
before
but i turned to my aunt when i got that
letter and said you know i think this
just means that for the first time in my
life
being poor has paid really well
so i didn't have access to that
information because the social networks
around me didn't have access to that
information
i learned from my community how to shoot
a gun how to shoot it well
i learned how to make a damn good
biscuit recipe the trick by the way
is frozen butter not warm butter but i
didn't learn
how to get ahead i didn't learn how to
make the good decisions about education
and opportunity
that you need to do to to make to
actually have a chance in this 21st
century knowledge economy
economists call the value that we gain
from our informal networks from our
friends and colleagues and families
social capital the social capital that i
had wasn't built for 21st century
america
and it showed there's something else
that's really important that's going on
that our community doesn't like to talk
about but it's very real
working-class kids are much more likely
to face what's called adverse childhood
experiences
which is just a famous word fancy word
for childhood trauma
getting hit or yelled at put down by a
parent repeatedly
watching someone hit or beat your parent
watching someone do drugs
or abuse alcohol these are all instances
of childhood trauma
and they're pretty commonplace in my
family importantly
they're not just commonplace in my
family right now they're also
multi-generational
so my grandpa parents the very first
time
that they had kids they expected that
they were going to raise them
in a way that was uniquely good they
were middle class
they were able to earn a good wage and a
steel mill but what ended up happening
is that they exposed their kids to a lot
of the childhood trauma that had gone
back
many generations my mom was 12 when she
saw
my grandma set my grandfather on fire
his crime was that he came home drunk
after she told him
if you come home drunk i'm going to kill
you
she tried to do it think about the way
that that
affects a child's mind and we think of
these things as especially rare
but a study by the wisconsin children's
trust fund found
that 40 of low-income kids
face multiple instances of childhood
trauma
compared to only 29 percent for upper
income kids
and think about what that really means
if you're a low income
kid almost half of you face multiple
instances of childhood trauma
this is not an isolated problem this is
a very significant
issue we know what happens to the kids
who experience that life
they're more likely to do drugs more
likely to go to jail
more likely to drop out of high school
and most importantly
they're more likely to do to their
children what their parents
did to them this trauma this chaos in
the home
is our culture's very worst gift to our
children
and it's a gift that keeps on giving
so you combine all that the hopelessness
the despair the cynicism about the
future
the childhood trauma the low social
capital
and you begin to understand why me at
the age of 14
was ready to become just another
statistic another kid who failed to beat
the odds
but something unexpected happened i did
beat the odds
things turned up for me i graduated from
high school
from college i went to law school and i
have a pretty good job now
so what happened well one thing that
happened is that my grandparents the
same grandparents of setting someone on
fire fame
they really shaped up by the time i came
around
they provided me a stable home
stable family they made sure that when
my parents weren't able to do the things
that kids need
they stepped in and filled that role
my grandma especially did two things
that really mattered one
she provided that peaceful home that
allowed me to focus on homework and the
things that kids should be focused on
but she was also this incredibly
perceptive woman despite not even having
a middle school education she recognized
the message that my community had for me
that my choices didn't matter
that the deck was stacked against me she
once told me jd
never be like those losers who think the
deck is stacked against them
you can do anything you want to and yet
she recognized that life wasn't fair
it's hard to strike that balance to tell
a kid that life isn't fair
but also recognize and enforce in them
the reality that their choices matter
but mama was able to strike that balance
the other thing that really helped was
the united states marine corps so we
think of the marine corps as a military
outfit and of course it is
but for me the us marine corps was a
four-year crash course and character
education
taught me how to make a bed how to do
laundry how to wake up early
how to manage my finances these are
things my community didn't teach me
remember when i went to go buy a car for
the very first time
i was offered a dealer's low low
interest rate of 21.9 percent
i was ready to sign on the dotted line
but i didn't take that deal because i
went and took it to my officer
who told me stop being an idiot go to
the local credit union and get a better
deal
and so that's what i did but without the
marine corps i would have never had
access to that knowledge
i would have had a financial calamity
frankly
last thing i want to say is that i had a
lot of good fortune in the mentors and
people
who have played an important role in my
life from the marines from ohio state
from yale from other places people have
really
stepped in and ensured that they filled
that social capital gap that it was
pretty obvious apparently that i had
that comes from good fortune but a lot
of children
aren't going to have that good fortune
and i think that raises really important
questions for all of us
about how we're going to change that we
need to ask questions about how
we're going to give low-income kids who
come from a broken home
access to a loving home need to ask
questions
about how we're going to teach
low-income parents how to better
interact
with their children with their partners
you'd ask questions
about how we give social capital
mentorship to low-income kids who don't
have it
we need to think about how we teach
working-class children
about not just hard skills like reading
mathematics but also soft skills like
conflict resolution and financial
management
now i don't have all of the answers
i don't know all of the solutions to
this problem
but i do know this in southern ohio
right now
there's a kid who's anxiously awaiting
their dad
wondering whether when he comes through
the door he'll walk calmly or stumble
drunkly there's a kid
whose mom sticks a needle in her arm and
passes out
and he doesn't know why she doesn't cook
him dinner and he goes to bed hungry
that night
there's a kid who has no hope for the
future
but desperately wants to live a better
life
they just want somebody to show it to
them
i don't have all the answers but i know
that
unless our society starts asking better
questions
about why i was so lucky and about how
to give that luck to more of our
communities
and our country's children we're going
to continue to have a very significant
problem
thank you